this man's phone is no doubt burning up
so i greatly appreciate him joining me
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
right here the day after the scouting
combine one week before the negotiating
window don't call it tampering window
opens up my colleague from the nfl media
group ian rappaport how are you ian i'm
good rich long time no see i know
saw you last night after dinner and
dessert and and everyone's like let's go
to the bar for some more and i'm like
i've got to do a show like i got to fly
and literally i made it here just in
time spoiling brockman's party he was
ready to actually uh start the show do
you want to do that
yeah i uh i also went to my room without
having a beer that's actually not sure i
had a beer but um it was a lovely night
it was lovely it was great i enjoyed
hanging out and uh yeah let's get back
to work all right let's do it where do
things stand right now with the packers
as you and i are talking ian
uh they are
awaiting aaron rodgers decision and i
know rogers is being criticized in some
places about taking a long time
uh on the other hand i get it because it
is a very very interesting and
complicated
decision for aaron rodgers and you know
it's
it's does he go back to the green bay
packers does he ask the team to
work out a trade with him for somewhere
and i believe that somewhere uh seems
the most likely somewhere would be the
denver broncos which is you know
honestly the same sort of place it has
been for some time
and then you know if you're rogers some
of this is going to be
you know if he is going to stay with the
packers he wants them to be able to run
it back and bring all the guys back and
that's one reason why he stayed
three or four extra days um with matlab
floor after the season to do some
long-term and short-term planning um but
it all kind of wraps up into one and it
is
um a very complicated situation for the
packers well so
uh we can guess who the guys are he
wants to run it back with right i mean
we're
yeah i mean one of them is the best
receiver in football
right and there's a franchise tag day
tomorrow um so
right that is that is something that
i guess it's all happening at once
in green bay
right now i mean hopefully um you know
he doesn't have to tell the packers
anything right i mean he has to
eventually but he doesn't have to
tell them anything by tomorrow the
thought was that he would do it by
tomorrow though so they know what they
need to do with devante adams the other
side of things are like
it sort of doesn't matter because
you know presumably they're going to tag
him anyway adams i'm talking about right
because
he is the best receiver in football and
if you're a team you'd prefer to have a
great receiver on your team than to play
for another team so
you know it's not like he actually needs
to let them know it's just that's when
everyone thought there would be a
decision so
as someone who would prefer to know what
aaron rodgers is doing i also would like
him to make a decision but he has not
asked me for miami i understand that now
we we say here on this show ian that uh
in the parlance of our business a
franchise tag is either applied or
slapped on a player based on the way the
player receives that franchise tag that
would be a slap that would be a slap for
uh
for devante adams right uh that would be
a slap i think that's fair to say and
consider the history here
uh you know they were talking about a
long-term deal
um
during last off season really through
[Music]
i think it was through the start of
training camp right because i had a
report that i think was around late july
um i can't remember what it was but
anyway it was sometime during training
camp where devante adams angrily cut off
talks with the packers and has not
actually resumed
long-term contract extension talks yet
uh he would like a long-term deal he
wants to be the highest paid uh receiver
in the nfl as he should given his talent
level but the problem is the deandre
hopkins deal is a weird one it remember
it was a short-term extension but it was
27 million dollars in new money
per year
and it has in a way become like a
like a stumbling block for receivers
because if you want to be the highest
paid you got to eclipse that but that
number is so high
that it's made it a really complicated
deal to do and they haven't gotten
anywhere as far as doing it
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show so having been in
uh indianapolis and you know on the
number of people that whisper in my ear
that i talk to
must be dwarfed by the number of people
that you do
what is the sense of arizona and kyler
murray
right now and how that might play out
yeah well i think most people think it's
going to be okay
i mean
there is a deal that they could do and i
think our i was reading this in uh
somewhere i think it was albert brewer
said today that kylo would like a deal
by the draft
uh
and i understand that but like i kind of
think i thought like if you're kyle
murray you'd rather wait until as long
as possible as you get up to the season
because maybe there's another
quarterback deal that gets done
somewhere maybe lamar gets done who
knows but anyway sounds like he wants it
before the draft and they can do a deal
um it's hard to do those deals sort of
at gunpoint um
but i guess you know the numbers are
pretty clearly defined right you have
dac at 40.
you have patreon homes of 45 you have
josh allen of 43
you can find a deal somewhere in there
so like if he really wants one like he
is their guy so they can do a deal so my
guess is it's going to be okay
um but the amount of saber rattling from
eric burkhardt was certainly noticed and
mentioned by several people in
indianapolis well i mean rogers is going
to reset it unless he's considered just
a totally different cat um because of
who he is and back-to-back mvps
but so
what are you hearing because we'll reset
it well what's he going to get and what
do you think i mean you know my guess is
it would be he'll be the highest paid no
doubt about it you know couldn't get to
50 i think it could
um that would be very high but you know
he is aaron rodgers so
and i think if you're going to have a
player who is the
you know first 50 really true first 50
million dollar quarterback like aaron
rodgers would be a pretty good one to do
if he's very good um it's you know it
also sort of depends on if you look at
the patch of a homes deal remember it
was a 10-year deal but it's basically
broken up into two pieces there's the
part of the deal where he makes 40
million then there's the part of the
deal where he makes 50 million the last
five years he averages 50 million so
theoretically that's the part that
rogers would want to break
so
my guess is he ends up at 50 and change
to do a new deal and you know
it's a lot of money but he's aaron
rodgers and it probably will end up
being a bargain anyway
so where where where does the the kyler
murray urgency come from then you know
wha where what's your best guess as to
why
you know this
this um
the scrubbing of the instagram account
happened at all and then the statement
is put out the monday of combine week
and now
you're hearing they want it done by the
draft what it what is the
the urgency
do you think well i think the i think
this started with the angst and
frustration from after the season you
know i'm i would assume those end of the
year meetings
um with
you know the team personnel where
everyone comes in day after the game is
frustrated
and
you know talks about how to get things
better but also expresses some
frustration i would imagine
after a long season when nerves are
prayed
um that probably started the ball
rolling there i'm so i think that's kind
of where this started was
you know the sort of fallout from the
end of the season where
they did what everyone feared they would
do which was limp to the finish and then
lose
um
but you know i think
i think he just wants it you know like i
haven't been able to figure out any
other reason
except he believes that he deserves it
and just wants it um and you know if
you're the cardinals i mean you might as
well as long as you know he's your guy
and i think we can pretty clearly say
that he is you guys would do a deal
earlier rather than later because
you're going to do it anyway so do it
when the price is a little bit cheaper
than it would be but even it doesn't
matter either way it's going to be very
exciting ian rappaport my colleague from
the nfl media group uh here on the rich
eisen show day after the combine
so one week from today the story do you
think will be what the big splash the
big um
signing that takes one guy from one team
to another what do you think that might
be
what's your crystal ball
this is a pretty good free agent class
um
so today's monday so pretty good free
agent class but i'm not sure that
um
it's really going to be
like
the actual free agents there's not a ton
of like super splashy guys where when
they sign you'll say oh my god i can't
believe this guy signed with you
there'll be some news obviously but to
me a lot of this still
will be about trade like
does russell wilson go anywhere does
jimmy garoppolo go anywhere how did the
quarterback shake out just to sean
watson get traded like i feel like even
with all the
um
you know
like free agent stuff the free agent
signings i do feel like the quarterbacks
will lord over all of it um hopefully it
gets shaken out sooner rather than later
so i can stop thinking about it because
it's only been like a year right um but
i think that's what sort of the big
story lines will be
and the uh quarterback
market how is it affected by what we
just saw at the combine who do you think
is
you know into pickett and willis and
maybe even matt corral what do you think
about that
so i would say
judging from the you know kind of the
way the combine was and there's some
good quarterbacks but i think it's safe
to say there's no surefire like you know
there's no
trevor lawrence there's no zack wilson
where you'll say i know i can get a
quarterback so i don't have to trade for
one my sense is
the quarterbacks this year almost won't
matter
when it comes to the draft
but when it comes to free agency i
should say so in other words
no one is going to be able to say oh
cool i don't
i don't need to get a quarterback
because i'm just going to draft this guy
there's no one that is a surefire come
in start right away guy
in the draft so everyone is going to
have to act
as if they are not going to draft a
quarterback
get their starter for next year and then
approach the draft and say okay should
we get one or not so like someone will
sign mr trubisky probably to start or
compete to start and then
maybe draft a quarterback as well or
something like that well i heard
drewbisky is going to get paid so much
that they're that he's the guy that's
what i'm hearing
what do you think i mean there was a lot
of those rumors in indy you don't know
where those rumors come from
um i i do think he'll be sort of top
free agent on the market
but i don't know that anyone is going
into the season being like
yes we want trubisky okay we got him
we're good looking for a quarterback
like now maybe he makes it that way and
that would be a pretty cool comeback
story right but i don't think that's the
belief going in so what what do you
think uh the ian rapport here on the
rich housing show what is the steelers
plan
you know what do you what do you think
what do you think about that one um
i think the steelers plan is to
take a long look at the veterans and if
one makes sense make a move whether
that's jimmy garoppolo or
you know travisky would be a potential
name there
um
and if they don't get the guy they want
to go in the draft like i think they're
looking at it you know they would like
to
they would like to be done in the chase
for quarterbacks because i know that
kevin colbert basically has told people
that he did not want to retire without
getting a
you know next franchise started for the
steelers just
this is kind of a weird year and
and you know i don't know who they're
going to get
then it's going to make everyone think
like okay we're done searching now
well it sounds like malik willis to me
that's what it sounds like to me to be
honest or you know kenny pickett shares
a building with them
they know him extremely well um
you know will he be available at 20
though they'd have to trade up they'd
have to trade up to go get him
well i mean that's going to be an
interesting storyline to follow because
like everyone sort of tells me that
these the quarterback run will start
late in the first round but like i've
been doing this long enough i know
what's happened
right like right oh yeah the
quarterbacks are late 20 you know late
20s and it's like well maybe early 20s
and then if you're going to take him it
let's say this dealers are going to take
him to 20. they're going to go okay hang
on do we need to move up now because
what if someone else and then they'll
all get drafted earlier than we think so
you know might they have to move up to
take them possible that's kind of what
i've been thinking about and then
there's the mother lode ian rap report
let's get to it right here
right here on the rich jazz show the
mother lode quarterback story
isn't aaron rodgers believe it or not it
just isn't even though he might get paid
50 million and could wind up in denver
or whatever happens with the packers
it's tb12 sir it's tb12 why
what's with the door
what's the door still open like he goes
on fred couples podcast just as we get
to indianapolis
you know talking about that he's going
to get through a little more vacation
time
no he's he's sleeping in his old bed you
know in his old house and when he gets
through all that then he'll see where
he's at right and
and then bruce arians is it just you
know even though i think that would
probably be uh
uh a glazer family decision if brady
says i want out i want to come back but
not with you or maybe he comes back with
them what is what is going on with tom
brady right now what do you think well
um there's two things that are going on
okay first of all i would assume it
sounds like
this is like so dumb but this is the way
somebody who knows brady very well
describes me i guess brady walks around
with a jug of water all the time
right to make sure that he's fully
hydrated and i made the joke to someone
who knows him very well and has known
him forever
i go i guess we can retire the jug
and this person looked at me like i was
crazy and was like oh no he's still got
the jug like he's still in shape
he's still eating well he's still doing
the tb12 method or whatever and he's
still keeping himself hydrated
in case he's still doing all the things
that he would do
in case he wanted to return
um i i don't know if he's gonna come
back i know it is at least possible and
i don't know where the level of possible
is but it is at least possible
i also know that lara fitzgerald still
has not retired and even last year when
it became clear that he was not going to
play for the hours on the cardinals he
still was like yeah we'll see i'm not
retired
um
you know
uh all of that so like it's like these
guys want to keep the door open
you know and maybe he's doing some of
that too
for what purpose i i mean like they
announced he's he's
he's uh running lines with jane fonda
one second and then the next minute he's
got the jug of water and his avocado ice
cream and
you know and and he's still he's still
sticking with the plant look i don't
expect him to just suddenly just
you know go get a bag of jelly beans and
just veg out on the couch but
this sounds like he wants to still play
i'll be very honest with you this is
this is definitely
somebody who sounds like he still wants
to play and aryan's his responses when
asked about
you know
about the possibility of letting him go
play elsewhere that i mean you could see
that really got i pissed him off like
you could see that
you could say i appreciate bruce area me
too much right because
it would be annoying if you you know you
go all in you get brady you win the
super bowl
and then if he wants to play somewhere
else like
for b.a to be like no you should play
for us or no now i will say this i've
seen all the rumors
um and the kind of reporting on brady
wanting to be in san francisco and i've
seen you know mike florios had some of
that
i have not personally corroborated any
of that now maybe my sources are not as
good i just i've had no one tell me that
he actually wants to play for san fran
well what about tampa though i mean
because clearly
we their their quarterback decision may
be just well we got gabbard he knows the
system
it's entirely possible that they might
shock everybody and go back to jameis
which you know would kind of be a bit of
a surprise but what if they just
maintain the status quo and now suddenly
it's june you know and then and then we
we give tom a call and say what do you
think you know yeah i mean
they it would not be the first big-time
quarterback to decide right around june
or start the training camp yeah i think
i'm just going to play um
the other thing is
you know i would expect them to be
looking around and taking a big swing
elsewhere anyway like deshawn watson
you know if i don't think russell wilson
russell wilson said on the today show
that he wants to play on the west coast
which sounds like no russ but you know i
would think they would take a showing it
to sean watson if his legal situation
clears up so i would kind of keep an eye
on that as well and what about last two
for you uh wentz
derek carr what do you got for me
i don't believe their car's going
anywhere okay um i i mean i know teams
would like him to go everywhere anywhere
but i just don't see that happening okay
carson wentz
is
like all the other quarterback
situations are awesome and fun and
fascinating and mind-numbing and all
those things
when it's biking most interesting to me
because i have no earthly idea what the
cults are going to do
and
i know they want to get better i know
they want to improve upon carson i don't
know who that's going to be and i don't
know how it makes sense
given the money to just cut them
and then sign like
mitchell trubisky or something
i mean i guess theoretically they could
do they could do anything you want
but like
are we sure that that's better and are
we sure that's worth it because during
the money like they're in a very very
very difficult spot and
unless i'm missing something dramatic
like i don't see how they get out of it
with a clear patch or the franchise
quarterback
man and carolina just sticks with sam
darnold or they they they do something
because washington's yellowing right
washington's doing the yolo plan they're
calling everybody this is amazing
everyone right um
you know i think caroline is in the
quarterback mitch too i think deshaun
watson will probably be in on some level
well when is he when are we going to get
some sort of that's that's the literally
the fourth time you've mentioned his
name but uh and and i don't i don't
i just one one when does that get you
know settled or or even solidified or
even remotely close in in the area of
him being a viable
option when does that happen
you know
uh i think they would like his legal
situation to be cleared up and you know
there is a possibility that in the next
several weeks the criminal matters
get decided uh is he going to the
charges it's been
it's been forever um you know i maybe
we'll get to draft time and we'll still
be talking about it like we were last
year right it's been so long that
at some point we're not talking about
desean watson it's going to feel very
weird to me
ian rappaport thanks for the time great
to see you uh in indianapolis and look
for my call again it's gonna be it's
gonna be pretty busy so thanks for the
time all right
always great hanging out on the phone
but more so in person that's exactly
right all right we'll talk good to see
you there you go this ian wrap reporter
i was sitting next to at dinner last
night
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here